yes 3 not deserved 6
4 6
to
all those to whom they are presented
in a few ways concerned
it has been extended to him that our late
sovereign the wool and zabeth two
died on September 8, 2022 and that by
his death the crown of canada and
flights to his highness press
artur jorge
us the right honorable but river side
governor general of
canada agreeing with the french
his majesty for canada proclaiming that
his royal highness prince charles and
arthur jorge
is now
the passing of our i  was so young
charles three years the grace of god
car united kingdom of canada and
its territories every black man
defender of the faith to whom we
recognize however the allegiances
lesmont five immense official this
sixth day of september
give
2022 vim
[Music]
[Applause  ]
[Applause]
to
[Music]
on
[Applause]
[Music]